alors ça c'est un sujet assez
intéressant et pas mal polémique je sais
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord les uns et
les autres sur ce sujet c'est un flou
juridique qui assure les réseaux sociaux
puisque pour réussir à cibler les jeunes
tout en contournant la législation de
nombreuses marques d'alcool n'hésite pas
à recruter des influenceurs c'est un
phénomène qui inquiète associations et
professionnels de la santé et c'est un
sujet de l'oeil du 20 heures
on se baladant sur le réseau social à la
mode instagram
on peut tomber sur ce genre de profil un
mannequin auprès de 600 mille abonnés le
jeune homme de 28 ans affiche dans un
décor de vacances une bière à la main
deux images pour lesquels il dit avoir
touché 4000 euros d'une agence
publicitaire
après pour les marines et bien au mois
de septembre cinq jours à positano en
italie tous frais payés dans un hôtel de
luxe mais c'était sexy le côté mer
double que l'on voulait sur ces photos
rien n'indique qu'il s'agit de publicité
encore moins que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
une mention pourtant obligatoire prévue
par la loi evin contacté la marque de
bière n'a pas souhaité nous répondre
ces postes instagram se multiplient et
scandalise cette association de lutte
contre l'alcoolisme
elle a décidé de porter plainte contre
ces marques d'alcool l'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé bien évidemment
je ne rappelle que c'est à consommer
avec modération c'est obligé de vous le
dire ici à la télé mais visiblement sur
instagram on n'attendait pas oublier de
vous le dire un peu même vous inciter à
boire avec des pubs qui ne se présentent
pas comme tel qu'est ce que vous en
pensez d'amiens bah moi je pense que
c'est assez hypocrite finalement parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin de ce genre de lois
comme la loi evin par exemple pour nous
expliquer que l'alcool tue enfin il ya
énormément d'autres choses qui tue par
exemple dès lors que vous voyez une
voiture lorsque la loi evin oui
exactement la loi evin en fait c'est une
loi qui empêche ou limite là les spots
publicitaires sur l'alcool à la
télévision et dans les médias le truc
c'est qu'il ya énormément d'autres
choses qui tue par exemple quand vous
voyez une voiture à la télévision vous
n'allez pas avoir une inscription en
dessous ses marques et les particules
fines nuisent à votre santé d'accord
mais ce que vous voulez dire par là ça
veut dire que
vous vous dites il faut arrêter avec la
loi evin faire dire je pense que toutes
ces lois là sont très infantile y est
lente pour les français parce qu'elles
partent du principe qu'on n'est pas
capable de se responsabiliser nous mêmes
je pense qu'il ya parfois des messages
qu'il est bon de rappeler même si tout
le monde les connaît et le fait de les
rabâcher de les répéter peut-être que ça
quand même eu d'incident et peut le
rappeler mais pas de la censure est une
publicité à l'étranger il est possible
de faire de publicité pour l'alcool très
rapidement caroline non mais je pense je
pense pas qu'il faille s'offusquer pour
tout et n'importe quoi on le voit il est
dans un cadre de la coque c'est pas
qu'il ait une bière à la main c'est la
beauté du corps dos non non non mais il
faut rappeler que ce sont les ambitions
de ces influenceurs donc la publicité
elle sert à pousser les gens à acheter
ou consommer un produit là ça les pousse
à consommer ou acheter de l'alcool
l'alcool aujourd'hui avec le tabac c'est
l'appareil à cause de mortalité en
france c'est un problème de centralité
de santé publique c'est pas parce que
monsieur simple et n'a pas compris ça
nos téléspectateurs faire la promo de
l'alcool sur un choc et vous est ce qu'à
60% pas choqué à 39% continuer de nous
dire ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag cqdm